so there's party we are now past halfway
let's have a look at e by examining her
concavity so we've kind of already been
doing this because it is the easiest way
to answer questions about acceleration
when you get given a graph or for that
matter when you're given an equation by
examining the concavity find the time
interval okay this is interesting so so
far in the questions ABCD they've been
asking us when when this when this so
that's kind of usually an instantaneous
moment in time but because they're
asking for what color might not used yet
brown they're asking for a time interval
so this is from when to win that an
interval has to have a start and an
endpoint right way in time I should say
so find the time until during which the
particles acceleration is negative
particles acceleration is negative so
because this corresponds to cavity we're
thinking about when is the graph concave
down now I chose orange but I've
actually sorry I've chosen brown but
I've actually used orange already to
describe part of this right because if
you have a look I started to look at
this section over on the left where it
was concave down so I can just kind of
continue that work and that will
complete my answer right so if I
continue over here this part here and
then I guess the orange section
continues to here until we reach that
point of inflection which is where there
is zero concavity this entire orange
orange section is concave down it's it's
a little bit like if you were to draw a
parabola through that right it's like oh
I've got this concave down that's really
hard to say let's make it a bit bigger
I've got this whole concave down section
looking here right I always go back to
parabolas because I'm really we've been
using them for years so much more
comfortable with them so this orange
section now I'll just get rid of that
awkward parabola that's the part I'm
interested in right so it's before times
six is what I'm what I'm going to answer
to Part II this is the time interval
during which the particles acceleration
is negative I'll write that down and
then we'll just quickly interpret that
so party
winters market here party acceleration
is negative between zero and six seconds
there's my there's my interval my time
interval this makes sense because if you
haven't think about this right um
the question is saying when is the
particles acceleration negative well in
this whole orange section right your
velocity is in the positive direction
but you can notice that you're sort of
slowing down at this point right your
velocity is positive but it's less and
less positive until you get to here
because your acceleration is against
your direction of motion right so
because you're accelerating against that
that's what slows you down colloquially
we use the word deceleration but that's
quite um ambiguous in a context like
this you're accelerating in the negative
directions that slows you down and then
at this point here you keep accelerating
in the negative direction which is when
why the particle starts to pick up speed
in the negative direction okay all right
so we're really on the homestretch now
we've just done parties so Part F says
at about what times the displacement the
velocity about the same as those at time
two so we have to say this approximately
because we're going to be doing some
some rough reading of the graph and like
we said before we don't have equations
so we can't solve this precisely we just
have to sort of eyeball it right so the
first thing to ask is well where are we
at time two on the graph what's
happening at that point so I'm going to
delete off all of this previous working
I think I've like used up all the colors
that I had so I'm just going to go back
to blue now time to where is that on
here well just like earlier when we're
looking at other time intervals here
I've only got multiples of three so I'm
gonna have to put on time two here so
you can see here I've got if I make that
three so it's probably I think that
roughly breaks us up that little spot
into thirds so that would make this one
and this two so now I'm going to go up
to the corresponding point on line
I spent graphs so that's going to draw
all the way up and you would use a ruler
obviously to do this if they handed this
to you on a piece of paper you use a
ruler and you go up to there and you can
see oh this is when this is where I am
rather this is where I am and I need to
find where I'm at the same position and
also where I'm at the same velocity okay
and let's do them one at a time so
position displacement is is what this
graph tells you about right it's a it's
a displacement graph okay so to know
when I'm it's the same displacement I
just need to know when am I at the same
place vertically speaking right so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna draw across a
line horizontally I'm only going to draw
to the right because it's pretty clear
to see that there's no point to the left
on the graph anyway I'm any earlier
point in time where this happens so when
I draw this horizontal line you can see
that at this point here or at this time
I should say and at this time over here
that's where we seem to be at this same
displacement I don't even know what this
test that displacement is I mean if I
had to guess you know it looks something
like it would be around seven but the
question doesn't ask me like what is
that actual place it just asks me when
and I at that same place and that's what
I get from this horizontal line that you
can see drawing across okay so now that
I have these two spots I'm going to draw
downwards
let's choose pink to my time axis like
so again you would use a ruler for these
so that you can get it reasonably
precisely okay so again because this is
approximate even though it's not bang on
I'm going to say look at this point here
looks like it's going to be about time
for and this point here looks like even
though it wasn't precise that was
probably down to the thickness of my dot
or my head on my line and that looks
like it was intended to land on the 12
okay so I'm going to say about what
times are they displacing about the same
as time - it's a time for in time twelve
so this is part if part one so at or
rather
laughter what do we say four seconds and
12 seconds I think we said yep after
four and twelve seconds so that's the
question of when I'm at the same
displacement when you're looking at part
two there ask you a question about
velocity now we've already said this
earlier in the question but I need to
remind you that velocity is about slope
it's about the the steepness of this
graph right so you can see here I'm
looking for what the gradient of this
curve is that will tell me DX ODT which
is velocity now my graph is already
looking for very busy so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna clear all this off and
you can see the value by the way of
using multiple colors and also the
importance of having a graph that's big
enough to put lots of information on
because I presume you don't want to
redraw this graph over and over again
which I have the benefit of doing
because of Technology so I actually
rubbed off more than I meant to so you
can see I actually want time to still be
there so I don't need this either so
there's my time to and what I'm looking
for is the slope of this line right so
I'm guessing if I were to eyeball it's
something like that I think this blue
highlight line here on its slope
roughly represents a tangent line to the
curve and so it's gradient which gives
me velocity I'm looking for another
place where the green is the same so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take this this part here this line it's
a little interval I notice for earlier
times all of these times the particle is
moving faster in the positive direction
it's steeper right so they're very good
as I move to the right you're like oh
well these parts here it can't be
possibly any section in here because you
know look at where my tangent is it's
got a positive gradient and all these
sections in here there's a negative
gradient so that's no good you can see
over here it's too steep so what I'm
looking for is that point along here at
some point I'm going to find that this
same gradient would be also tangent to
the curve and as you can start to
approach down here you can see this
looks like this is the spot that's bang
on I'm how would you do this when you
don't have an iPad that you can just
move around you would usually use a
ruler right in exactly the same way that
I got the tangent line over on that spot
there I would place my ruler there in
exactly the same way and
look for where the ruler I would move
the ruler along in a parallel fashion
until I find this other point here which
gives me something with a parallel
tangent okay
in fact what I'll do is I'm just so that
you can highlight that what I'll do is
I'll just duplicate it so you get
another one
okay so I hope that you guys can see
that this tangent would be rough if well
I mean I've driven what drawn them
exactly parallel so I'm gonna say that
looks like about there right which again
approximately reading down that looks to
me you know if that's nine and then I
guess that would be ten because you
would put eleven just a little bit
further so that I'm reading as time ten
so I can now say the velocity is about
the same after about ten seconds so I'm
going to write that down here I might I
might distinguish as well between this
question in the previous one because
this is displacement is approximately
equal
after that amount of time because the
question I'm doing right now is not
about displacement
it's about velocity velocity just so you
don't have to sit there watching me
write this is approximately equal after
we said ten seconds on the graph what
stop